more than 35 years after the Empire
Strikes Back was released there's
something about the Star Wars sequel
that still doesn't sit right with Mark
Hamill at the beginning of the 1980
blockbuster Mark Hamill's iconic
character Luke Skywalker is captured by
a massive snow beast called a Whomper on
the icy planet of Hoth to get away
Skywalker uses his lightsaber to slice
off one of the creatures arms but that
apparently wasn't what Hamill signed up
for I'm all revealed on Twitter he was
originally under the impression that
Luke wouldn't actually hurt the Whomper
when filming the scene I was assured my
lightsaber swiped toward camera the
creature was not on set but simply sent
its fur to scare him off horrified to
later see amputation and unnecessary
cruelty
womper was hungry not evil Luke would
never do this the comments echo
statements Hamill has made about the
scene in the past on his show mark
Hamill's pop culture quest remember
saying well I'm just grazing his fur
right this is what do you mean I said
well it's like a Hungry Bear he's not
evil yeah so I should just scare him off
not only did I cut off his arm but they
do an insert of it follow the topic came
up when a fan shared a photo of a cake
made to look like a 7 1 per arm for
national cake day but Hamill and
outspoken animal lover said he's still
angry about the scene of course the
special edition of Empire Strikes Back
has an even more graphic version of the
Wampus shown bloody and screaming a
Twitter user responded that it all
seemed gratuitous heck it was even in
the book Luke use the Force to sense the
wampas mind and more applied my acting
was much better in the book this isn't
the first time Luke's battle with the
Whomper has made headlines as a deleted
scene from Empire Strikes Back seem to
suggest a fight was added to explain the
facial scars Hamill suffered in a 1977
car accident
that is very real well scars over going
there so we'll find out how Luke feels
about a whole new batch of creatures
when star wars our last Jedi hits
theaters on December 15th hopefully he's
kinda to pause and Chewbacca rez thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]